the relationship between Peter Parker
and Tony Stark is so special over the
five films that Tom Holland has
portrayed spider-man in the MCU that we
needed to see where his journey went and
see how does spider-man step out of the
shadow of his mentor Tony Stark and
become the true hero that he was always
meant to be
and it's for that reason that endgame
and spider-man far from home are two
essentially two pieces of the same story
and it's not over yet hey everybody it's
Charlie's surprise we have some hot off
the presses
spider-man MCU Marvel Sony updates I
wasn't expecting some so quickly but
it's not the best news ever the CEO of
Sony's movie studio just did a big
interview with Variety I'll explain what
he said during that because he also
explains what's going on with spider-man
3 venom to the Morbius movie in the six
count them six spider-man TV shows that
they're currently developing despite all
the stuff that's going with them trying
to take spider-man out of the MCU we're
doing the giveaway for Disney Plus
memberships all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your best
spider-man 3 spider-man 4 theory on the
video you all remember the funny Tom
Holland video the other day where he was
answering questions talking about Miles
Morales crossover in the spider-man
movies do you think that both models and
Peeta could coexist in the same universe
or do you think Peter would have to die
first before they establish - well I
hope that doesn't happen because I would
love to share the screen with Miles I
think that'd be really cool and I don't
want to die because I really love
playing Peter Parker the timing of that
seemed really weird Tom Holland isn't
going to be releasing any more movies
till December so why is he doing this
big GQ spread well it's probably
partially damage control on Sony's part
because of all this MCU Marvel's
spider-man fall out so breaking down the
new spider-man interview with a Sony CEO
from yesterday starting with number 5
fans holding out hope the spider-man
might be returning to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe will be disappointed
to hear that the door is closed on that
deal he went on to say that it's a long
life implying that maybe way way down
the road something could be done about
it
but for now for the next couple of years
definitely no sharing arrangement would
be made
spider-man is out of the MCU effectively
he says there's no ill will quote
quote between Sony and Marvel after the
two failed to reach an agreement on
financing terms for the upcoming
spider-man movie they clarified what was
going on with that because when the news
broke a couple weeks ago there was a lot
of confusion over what Disney was asking
for in the new contract in what Sony was
willing to offer because that was the
big blowout that was the reason why they
both walked away from the table Disney
wanted to co-financed all of Sony's
spider-man movies that includes anything
spider-man related the venom movies the
Morbius movie any other potential
live-action spider-verse movies and the
animated spider-verse movies at a rate
of 30% to Sony's 70% right now Sony
finances all those a hundred percent so
they wind up earning the majority of the
box-office money after the film's hit
theaters so Disney was asking for a 30%
stake in that they're saying that we'll
pay 30% of the cost to make all these
films but as part of that we also get
way more potential profits on the back
end if the movies are successful
Sony said No Deal then they both walked
away from the table and that was the end
of it that's when you started hearing
the news about spider-man leaving the
MCU number four during that interview
the Sony CEO also lays blame for the
deal falling through on Kevin Feige
being quote-unquote stretched too thin
with all the new Marvel phase 4 Marvel
phase 5 projects that Disney has him
working on which i think is complete
bull crap but his quote reads we had a
great run with Feige on the spider-man
movies we try to see if there's a way to
work it out the Marvel people are
terrific people we have great respect
for them but on the other hand we have
some pretty terrific people of our own
Kevin didn't do all the work so that's
him trying to say that the Sony people
that worked on all the spider-man Marvel
movies so far are also really good like
Sony can still make good spider-man
movies the animated spider-man into the
spider verse is a really good example
that spider-man 2 is still one of my
favorites spider-man films of all time
so it is possible for Sony to make a
good spider-man film without Marvel's
help but just a little while ago the
Sony people were also saying that Kevin
Feige also helped them on the DL with
their previous spider-man films so
anytime spider-man films have done
really well or really poorly everyone is
always really quick to place the blame
on someone else the Sony CEO went on to
say spider-man was fine before the event
movies talking about the Avenger
crossovers Avengers infinity war
Avengers endgame the Marvel movies they
did spider-man homecoming spider-man far
from home then says now that we have our
own universe talking about the venom
verse that they've been developing he
will play with other characters as well
that's him talking about the spider-man
venom eventual crossover maybe not
spider-man 3 but more likely spider-man
4 or venom 3 because it seems like
they're building up to venom maximum
carnage with those movies
[Music]
[Applause]
we have to stop him
together
[Applause]
for those of you hoping the Sony might
sell its studio and Marvel had a chance
to get the spider-man rights back he
also added that there was no chance that
Sony Pictures would ever be for sale so
number two he also explains what they're
doing with the six new spider-man TV
shows that they're developing at Sony so
that sounds crazy I know and you're like
wait a minute doesn't Marvel have the
rights to spider-man TV shows because
all the animated spider-man TV shows so
far have come from Marvel not from Sony
[Music]
right now apparently what the deal is is
that Marvel has the rights to make
spider-man TV shows that are under 40
minutes in length so that means
half-hour animation that's where you get
to all the animated spider-man TV shows
that have been airing the last couple of
years
Sony has the rights to make live-action
hour-long drama television shows that's
how Sony is able to do these six
live-action spider-man TV shows although
I don't know that all them are gonna
wind up being live-action
he didn't say exactly where they would
be airing either whether they go to
Netflix or whether they'd be on regular
cable channels or major network TV but
six live-action spider-man TV shows
sounds crazy that probably means some
sort of venom TV show that probably
means a spider-man into the spider-verse
TV show straight up with most of those
characters they talked about doing an
animated spider pig TV show I'm working
like a dog trying to sniff out the
latest story hi can I dance you have a
live-action Miles Morales TV show a
live-action spider-gwen TV show before
those characters both show up in the
live-action movies with Tom Hollands
Peter Parker because they own the rights
to the spider-man character in the
movies and now live-action TV shows they
have access to over 900 different
characters so when you're thinking about
what these live-action TV shows are
gonna be just think about their biggest
characters that you don't think are
gonna be in a movie right away like
we'll see a new version of the sinister
six
in the movies way before we ever see
them on the TV shows they didn't
announce a release date for any of these
shows but I'm guessing if they're just
starting working on them now then it'd
probably be 2021 before they hit Netflix
or a major network or wherever they
decide to put them in as bad as all this
new Sony spider-man news is that does
confirm that Marvel can do a what-if
animated episode for both of the
spider-man movies they've done so far
spider-man Home Coming and spider-man
far from home because back at d23 Kevin
Feige revealed that there will be 23
what-if episodes one for each MCU movies
so far so it'd be a different ending
different sequence of events one of them
being Marvel Zombies we actually got a
bigger preview of that with a bunch of
teasers I'll do a breakdown of that
sometime in the next couple of days
because it looks really cool so this
just can
firms that they can continue to use
spider-man in those half-hour animated
episodes just not in the MCU movies
anymore you guys can let me know in the
comments though which live-action shows
do you think they're actually gonna wind
up doing in number one probably the
biggest question after this giant
interview is if the Sony CEO is saying
that it's gonna be a long time before
they ever come back to the table what
does that mean for Avengers five
spider-man four Marvel phase four Marvel
phase five in everything that they've
been setting up with him being the heir
apparent to Iron Man especially through
the Edith glasses he is access to this
giant orbital weapons platform are they
just gonna ignore that in future movies
how are they get a reference spider-man
because now it sounds like even though
they'll be able to use some of the
characters that they shared in some of
the storylines there's no way that
Marvel is gonna let Sony go off on its
own and use Iron Man stuff because
that's their a player no big Avengers
characters showing up in the Sony movies
and Sony is also probably gonna try and
do everything they can to prevent
spider-man's stuff from showing up in
future Marvel movies everybody post your
theories and your reactions in the
comments below this is just the
beginning of it I'm sure that the drama
will continue but I'll be doing venom 2
videos as they start to shoot that in
the next month we have the Joker movie
coming up I'll do more videos for that
we also have all the Disney plus stuff
ramping up later this year if you're big
Rick and Morty fan rick and morty season
4 is gonna be coming so there is some
good stuff coming despite all the bad
spider-man news while you wait for
everything click here to re-watch that
funny Tom Holland video and click here
to watch Robert Pattinson explain the
Batman movie thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]